I have a tweet
and y'all have been lighting up the chat
about it I said there's a nine
millimeter bullet lodged in my kitchen
now I can't say I'm surprised it's
happened after the wave of doxing and
threats made against us
I can't reveal too much of the details
about what happened but this morning I
got word that my house had been
um I don't know what the right word is
burglarized is the legal term but people
typically think burglary implies theft
of goods there was no theft there was uh
reportedly two men who broke in climbed
through a window
one of our staff members on site alert
yelled out
let me just say very carefully a shot
was fired the individuals were nearly
struck they fled they left behind a
wallet and an ID which is very very
strange nothing appears to have been
missing and we don't know what this was
about okay entirely possible that this
was a random occurrence considering
we've been swatted so many times
considering we have active threats and
the far left has been posting uh let's
just say posting an address that they
believe is my house it's not on the
internet excessively
the first thing we thought was seems
like it may be random or
um localized and then after going over
the scenario talking with some
individual security for instance we were
like okay actually it seems like this
might actually be political because the
things we would expect from a burglary a
typical burglar in the area didn't
happen the property in question is is
large with multiple buildings on it and
without giving too many details away we
ultimately concluded that your typical
robbery wouldn't occur in a situation
like this I don't know exactly what
happened
um you know we just know that it did
uh that's what's been reported by well
we have the police report that was filed
the police took evidence and um
the reason why I want to bring this up
is that I've been talking about I talked
about this last week
we've been swatted uh several times and
we've not reported it uh everybody knows
that we've been swatted over a dozen
times at the bomb squad here and
everything like that and we keep being
told by uh people don't say anything
don't let anybody know what's happening
and the first the first time I heard
that I'm like it's kind of odd like
shouldn't we let people know that there
are people trying to murder us because
then like I don't know it just feels
like if something happens no one will be
prepared for it we should be like hey
guys these threats are real they're
happening and what we kept being told
was if you say it it will it will keep
happening and I'm like okay you know
what I agree it's a tired narrative so
we actually stopped mentioning that
swattings were happening guess what they
still keep happening guess what after
all the the death threats and and
threats against us I don't blame Elon
Musk you know I I've I've I was thinking
about reaching out to him being like
dude there are people posting addresses
for me Matt Walsh and a variety of
people and they are spamming them and
mass like crazy there's got to be some
way of getting rid of this but I'm like
what do you really do how do you really
deal with this
so now my attitude is is basically this
the left came out and we'll talk about
the story in a second and said that a
Transformer substation was shot up by
far right Wingers trying to shut down a
drag performance
every single time something happens
jussie Smollett 2.0 they claim the far
right the far right last week one of our
guests said if you go to the average
person and ask them who's more likely to
commit political violence a left Winger
or a right-winger they will tell you
outright a right winger despite the fact
that it's substantially more likely to
come from the left just in every
capacity I know the ADL has their weird
rankings but they claim that black
nationalists are left-wing and white
nationalists are right-wing and none of
that makes sense
and I think that there's a reason for it
how often does Ben Shapiro talk about
the threats that he gets rarely if ever
how often does your typical antifa talk
about the threats they get they won't
shut up about anything they get a DM
where someone says you're fugly and
they'll post it and say I'm under attack
they're trying to kill me so what
happens The Narrative you start seeing
in mainstream conversation is the left
is constantly being threatened and the
right is fine when in reality this stuff
is happening to us so I don't know if
this incident in question was political
but I find it hard to believe it's a
coincidence has happened around the time
that people have been spamming you know
people have been posting on Twitter that
we shouldn't be allowed to live
comfortably but I don't know what you
guys think the story is a little
perplexing because it sounds like I'm
not gonna you know be careful yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not gonna you
know I I I I I know the drill I've been
through this before it's this has been
you know our entire career this is
nothing new I mean except the more the
the levels of intensity keeps
um just keeps getting uh you know higher
and higher but I was going to say this
is uh this is either a case of the wet
Bandit from home alone or just someone
messingly uh messing with with us so
um just deliberately trying to
intimidate and scare us so I I think you
know again who knows what's really going
on here I think a lot of the things are
done to confuse people it could be a
bunch of idiots
um you know poverty is increasing a lot
of people are poor a lot of people are
desperate but but the official story of
what happened doesn't really add up to
that doesn't really make sense and the
idiocy of it it doesn't really make
sense at all especially with the
identification card
um yeah that that right that way there's
like okay either they're the lowest IQ
idiots of all time the dumbest criminals
of all time or someone's deliberately
trying to you know send a message well
remember when the planes hit the World
Trade Center
um a passport fell out of the burning
explosion explosion and fell down to the
ground that's how they found the
terrorists that did it that's a good
point
it may just be that this guy who broke
in had a wallet with nothing but a
single ID in it and my understanding is
the ID wasn't even in it when they fled
so that means he he climbed in and just
said oh I better check my wallet for my
ID and took it out place it down looked
at it and then had to play the building
how convenient that now we have a wall
an identification and someone to go
after how convenient I don't like this I
don't like talking about it publicly but
what I will talk about is the victim
mentality because I know what you mean
about people claiming oh they hurt me
they're violent towards me but you never
hear Ben you don't hear Ben Shapiro say
when he gets docs you don't hear Disney
say when they get doxed because
entertainment companies get docs that's
what happens that's why they have big
walls around their their studio
um but at some point
I don't like playing the victim card I
don't like being like he's I got hit
today everybody look how sad I am oh I
got hurt today everyone look at me look
at me but at some point I mean it's
worth being honest about what's
happening not complaining about it it's
just the nature of the entertainment
industry
there's one reason I tweeted about it
when I heard right so I wake up in the
morning and phones are going nuts
because it happened at 7 A.M like I wake
up and like I'm in bed getting up
getting ready and it's literally
happening I wasn't at this property in
question
and um I said look I've I've told people
please For the Love of All That is Holy
if you hate my guts if you don't want me
to be alive whatever do not come to my
properties you're allowed to hate me you
can hate hate me all you want but if you
come to these properties there is a
strong possibility you will lose your
life no one is going to sit back and be
like well despite all the death threats
um I'm gonna give this person a bit of
the doubt as they shatter the window and
climb through I don't know what they're
doing but you know let's just ask them
politely that's not what any of our
security guys are going to do no the
security guys you're lucky if if you're
uninjured when you leave the guys who
are probably hurt so that that's the
main reason I was like you know I talked
about it and said I think I should put
that out just so that like I can make
sure this is loud and very clear
you know I do not want anyone getting
hurt and if you come here so we have
people trying to troll we have stupid
games and there's a reason why
you know who knows some some morons
you know coming up I have no idea
but uh I I just you know I have to
wonder about with all of this going on
the other significant portion of the
story is that
it's been a year since we uh the
swattings began and we've been swatted
on average more than once per month
sometimes twice
where's law enforcement I've I've tried
to reach out to some the amount of
crimes that have been committed against
us in terms of violent and as well as
what I what I'd consider like white
collar crimes if we could talk about it
people would would crap their pants but
we can't because active investigation
self-law enforcement but for some reason
nothing's being done about it
I think I realized something a scary
thing Marjorie Taylor green was spotted
what six times
six she's a city member of Congress you
mean they can do nothing to protect a
city member of Congress
okay well that says everything right
there the courts and law enforcement are
incapable of actually maintaining social
cohesion at this point the we hear all
of these stories about uh the summer of
love the deaths from the the 30 plus
people dead from antifa and there's zero
accountability towards any of it
sounds to me like
maybe it's not Civil War in the sense
that people uh expect as we often say
like two sides fighting it's just a
collapse of social cohesion
the the FBI the doj are working with big
Tech to benefit the Democrats they're
not going after the people protesting in
front of the justices homes they are
going after pro-life activists social
cohesion is shattered completely
the courts are unable to do anything the
crimes are getting worse I wonder if
they ever were able to do anything and
if it was always just like the the
Visage of strength and force like the
fear of threat of of the cops there's so
there's a lot of like 30 cops and like
700 000 people they'll have like weird
you know ratios like that like one cop
to 700 humans No One Cop can't stop nine
guys like not realistically maybe that
that maybe that's it maybe they've never
been able to do it you know but I don't
know
yeah look it's it's pretty scary and I
think that you actually bringing it up
is smart in the sense of people
understanding that there is a threat on
the other side of this kind of like
fictitious wall that everybody wants to
cross to try and scare whether it's you
or somebody else and I think you can see
it in California right so I'm in
Huntington Beach which is Orange County
up in Los Angeles there was this huge
kind of rash of all these grabbing you
know Smash and grab into the jewelry
stores where they just they come in they
grab everything and there were certain
situations where people would fight back
well then they start to move into Orange
County now Orange County is notorious
for being very different political lead
in Los Angeles a little bit looser on
the concealed carry laws what happens
when they come in they hit Huntington
Beach they go into a jeweler which is
right down the street from us guy is
care the guy has a concealed carry pulls
his gun out shoots three of them there
was four different cars because they do
these in these big groups well you know
what I never heard of again after that a
smash and grab in Orange County yeah
very true but you hear about them in
Beverly Hills you hear about them on Bel
Air everything like that oh yeah they're
still happening all the time I mean
they're happening up in La like and I
mean it's just kind of an everyday thing
now yeah you you know people now
actually they have tourists that go to
La and they they're just sitting waiting
to see if they can videotape or Smash
and grab instead of going to no I'm just
kidding yeah you'll get lucky one day
there's enough to happen Jordan Peterson
talks about this a lot more eloquently
than I could ever can saying if you uh
are prepared for violence the likelihood
of violence coming your way is uh
reduced essentially saying if you learn
self-defense you you will learn how you
absolutely don't need it in many
instances you know a lot of the stuff
out in the streets is is a lot of the
times when it comes to conversation and
fights a lot of it is ego a lot of it is
just people not knowing when to walk
away but when someone comes into your
house I mean that's another level that's
another thing to to really kind of take
seriously uh you know people should
always have the right to to defend
themselves but also know exactly what
they're doing they should receive
training
um and they should take the situation
very seriously because you know as time
goes on I think it's only fair to say
that especially in in major city areas
people are going to become more poor a
lot of them are going to become more
desperate and a lot of the major cities
are going to become a lot more Lawless
and the only person you could really
depend on yourself for defending
yourself is you yeah no one else the the
[ __ ] people that want to hurt kill
violently don't care about them the
Constitution they're going to get a
weapon and do it you can't stop that the
constitution protects people from
Legally defending themselves the Second
Amendment particularly like the threat
of retaliation is what has protected the
United States for about a hundred
thousand years
um but like the reason why people aren't
dropping drone I mean there has been
attacks on You could argue on the United
States 911 being an instance of someone
attacking the United States uh
but it's the fact that we're all armed
and ready to just snap back with nuclear
weapons with you name it orbital strikes
people do not mess with that because
they don't want to get obliterated and
it's the same with menial criminals on
the street if they know you're packing
they're not going to touch you they're
going to look for someone that's been
legally muted and not able to have a
weapon or something like that or someone
that's elderly or vulnerable you know
it's disgusting but that's reality this
is what I can't understand about
California right I mean if you're if
you're one of these ultra wealthy
celebrities as stalkers living in the
Hills what do they just got to hire like
50 armed guards around their house all
the time like why wouldn't you want to
be armed I don't I never understood that
personally
maybe the rich people are allowed to be
armed is that it a lot of them a lot of
them are a lot of them just have massive
walls which uh you know aren't big
beautiful 30-foot walls yeah yeah true
big big beautiful beautiful as they call
for open borders I do like big walls
I've come to really appreciate a large
walled compound or our walls or fences
and Gates around your house I like you'd
love South Africa man everybody's walled
in oh it's walls it's fences it's
everything is that because it's like
posts colonialism crime is pretty
serious there right yes crime in South
Africa is rather serious business and
can you have guns yes and uh you can get
guns relatively easily but uh yes
legally protected people can be armed in
South Africa
um I don't know for sure probably not
but everyone has private security anyway
so yeah isn't it like there's like
private police basically because they're
so good companies are so big yeah what
is that like basically everyone has
private security because the police
force doesn't really work or in some
cases the police force works but they
won't come out or they're like oh it's
too dangerous or it'll be like oh we'll
be there but they'll be there in 40
minutes and by that time you know things
have already elapsed it's not really
it's been your better interest to have
weapons and have firearms and be ready
to protect yourself at all costs because
uh you know the sa police force is not
going to be yeah they did the same thing
in Detroit I believe I believe there's a
full report of individuals just hiring
private uh security that was armed and
them doing a lot better job than police
officers that of course are giving
people tickets and generating revenue
for the state or shutting down small
businesses for daring to defy lockdowns
what um how do you guys handle
restaurant security and you don't have
to be specific if it's all under the you
know behind closed doors conversation
but what do you guys do yeah no that's
actually a great question
um because restaurants are targeted
pretty heavily especially given the the
cash nature of restaurants and then of
course you know the fact that there's so
many people that actually go into the
restaurants and the reason why I say
that's a risk now is because they
actually they're targeting places where
there are a lot of people with Handbags
and jewelry Etc and they're just robbing
everybody in the restaurant so uh you
know cameras look you know chefs with a
ton of knives and most of of them have
psychological disorders that's I
wouldn't want to cross that line but
you know what I think is kind of
happening is there's a distributed
denial of service in terms of crime
occurring crimes we see these videos of
people shoveling stuff into bags at
Walgreens or Target or whatever uh
rampant violent crime in New York
skyrocketing everywhere it's so much
crime happening at once yeah that not a
single one can actually be solved so you
know if crime is at a certain level the
police are able to prosecute an arrest
and stop some of it but once it goes
slightly above that level
you got 10 phone calls and they're all
saying I got to deal with this problem
the cops are like yeah we can I mean
first of all if the cop was going to
arrest that guy that guy that guy that
guy that guy that guy that guy they'd
have to go and testify to each of those
instances in court several times not not
always sometimes it's like open and shut
case but not but it's just impossible
like you you were mentioning thirty
thousand forty thousand cops in New York
City to 13 million people in the Metro
2.5 million in Manhattan but it's
impossible to deal with and then and
then if you throw in even the slightest
sophistication to the crime itself well
now you're dealing with a whole nother
level we had a we had a team member who
was a scammer we didn't know it total
con artist and then it's ripping us off
for thousands and thousands of dollars I
believe the story and wasn't going to
prosecute it first and then we got uh
the police involved they were like oh
this is a they've done it before look at
their background this now I said let's
go after them then we want we got to
stop this dead in the tracks et cetera
et cetera and they're like oh we're not
gonna do anything about it right like
well you know how much Manpower that
takes and the case that we have to make
and keep as you said go back go back so
even if it's you know the slightest bit
of sophistication where it requires more
than 30 minutes or there's not a literal
Smoking Gun you're right and it's not
just like minor crimes it's not just
home invasions it's also murders it's
also uh people men forcing themselves on
women it's also assaults in the adult
nature there's there's horrible crimes
that go unpunished because the cops are
like well we just can't do anything or
some cops just don't feel any initiative
or or have no reason to actually stop or
try to prevent or trying trying to get
any justice at all there's no reason for
them I was talking to a lawyer about the
swattings and about Marjorie Taylor
green and I said what is the process for
dealing with federal crimes I said of
course you contact the U.S attorney in
the area where you know the crime is
being committed or whatever and I said
so we've got
14 or 15 swattings at this point bomb
squad shut up twice Studio's been
evacuated how do they have nothing and
not only that but we actually have a ton
of evidence we have a ton of
circumstantial evidence statements made
by potential suspects and you know other
stuff I I don't want to reveal too much
because I don't want to give it I don't
want anyone to realize exactly what we
have and they're just like oh yeah yeah
they look at it and they're like wow
that's that is that is compelling uh
FBI's underfunded understaffed and
uninterested and I'm like okay but they
can go after they can go to Roger
Stone's house at three in the morning or
whatever or they can they yeah they can
do this kind of stuff where they they
arrest uh some they raid the home of
some lady and was it FBI who rated the
home of some Lady in Alaska because I
thought she was at January 6th or
something yep yeah they can do stuff
like that they can go after 12 12 agents
and go after a pull rope at a garage oh
yeah I remember that one but we can't be
like here is a stack of evidence from a
private security company we think we
know who's doing it and they're like
sorry in times of like uh of a golden
age where we were in like a time of
insane Prosperity from 1970 tonight to
now you know in the United States where
you could call the police and they'd
come to your house and be like what's
wrong can I help you like uh if Society
starts to break down in any fashion
defer to the Constitution you have the
First Amendment and the Second Amendment
to back you up you have the right to
defend yourself in your property in this
country I want to jump to this next
story but but real quick I just want to
say
um uh as of 8 P.M news broke that Kirsty
alley has passed away oh man yeah a
tweet on Kirstie Alley's uh page says
sad to inform that our Fierce loving
mother has passed away after battle with
cancer so rest in peace someone someone
super chatted and I was kind of like
what you know because I have to just
joke and then I pulled it up yeah so
rest in peace sad to hear yeah I was
gonna say that I loved look who's
talking as a movie but it's like you
know what Christy God bless you my man
woman love you your family everybody out
there the alleys whatever your last
names are love you guys sorry to hear
but beautiful human well life is short
you got to cherish every moment you have
and you got to protect it too thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time